I think we always imagined that all the
generations of women before us were
perfectly happy to lose their maiden
name and take their husband's name and
I'm sure that's not true
so in Britain patrilineal surnames go
down through the male line down through
the generations surname systems aren't
the same all the way around the world
yes match the patriarchy what I had read
about a couple where the husband took
the waist name that's interesting you
said it's our choice and if it means
that much to you then I'll take your
name and I cried but my dad was really
confused and it's his name no he's just
like is that legal yes
[Music]
I was Brian Mackin and I was Rona wells
and then afterwards we were both [ __ ]
wells
one word without a dash in between and I
really wanted us to be sort of Oh
one name to a family unit I believe
there's a rabbit farm somewhere in the
north of England that is called McComb
walls there's only three of us in the
world
yeah exactly and a raft Fran and so my
dad is called Clyde my mother is called
an cliven and Claire pfann Levon that's
my surname and cliff is a bit gross
isn't it and cliff where it's clear I'm
just that just rolls off the tongue if I
hadn't come
my parents didn't just want me to kind
of lazily take the surname of my dad and
the second thing is that my mom really
wanted people to know that I was Welsh
but my first girlfriend flora we thought
that we had a kid oh it could be called
flop in but in Spain people have double
barrelled surnames
the father's surname is also followed by
the mother's surname that actually
reveals the ancestry through the male
line but from the mother's side and from
the father's side as well Pablo Picasso
his mom's last name is actually Picasso
and he just used Picasso my mum is doing
the family tree she has managed to get
to the 15th century which is a lot let's
look at gender equality in the surnames
so if everyone has a double-barrelled
name and you only pass along the surname
according to your gender that actually
solves a lot of problems let's take a
celebrity example let's say we have in
the far future vivian jolie-pitt
married to leave on Thurman hop Vivian
because she's a woman would take her
mom's name Jolie and leave on because
he's a man it would take his dad's name
talk so you get
the Jolie Hawks so this system has loads
of advantages it's really fair to both
sides of the family half siblings will
always share at least one surname if you
get married a few times you still retain
part of your name which is really
important for a lot of people's identity
it works just as well for same-sex
couples as it does for opposite sex
couples because really you can just
choose whichever of the surnames to keep
and pass on it makes exploring your
ancestry way easier in 1934 the law was
passed that every Turkish citizen had to
adopt a surname there was a rush on all
this fancy names like eel drum which
means flash or lightning you have a lot
of these names in Turkish it's like Hawk
Wolf lion brave or tall so Esther
meaning the real Turk I was born and
raised in Germany and my children and
they're gonna be living here in the UK
so are they really the real Turks I
think maybe my grandfather would have
been really disappointed by that you
know one surname is used for
professional communication the other one
is for personal the online persona might
actually be more significant than our
legal documents because it provides much
more information about who we are
[Music]
people seem to accept a surname not as a
matter of choice that may be changing if
so that's probably a good thing so it
has made me who I am but that's part of
a much broader picture about where the
name comes from and the reasons for
doing it just the fact that we have a
choice I think it doesn't matter what
you choose but choose actively yeah it's
nothing wrong with taking a husband's
name if you want if you had a better
last name but I might well have taken it
when him was token Shakespeare then
you'd have had a hard time arguing not
stay that night maybe maybe